in the previous video we looked at how
angles are measured using degrees the
other notation we use to measure an
angle is
radians very few people actually know
what a radian means with respect to
angles everyone knows how they can
convert degrees to radians and vice
versa but as I said very few people
understand the concept of
radians this video is a bit long but
trust me it's full of of interesting
Concepts to understand what radians
means we need to draw a
circle let o be the center of the circle
and let R be the radius now let me take
this radius and place it like this the
length of this red segment will also be
R now we just need to push this red
segment from the top such that it lies
entirely on the circumference of the
circle like this the length of this red
part part is still R it has just become
curved that's all the curved length
starts from here and ends here now from
the center of the circle we draw another
radius that joins the other end point of
the red curve this length will also be r
as its radius so let's analyze the
figure we have an ark of length equal to
the radius of the circle and the two
radi joining the center and the end
points of that Ark remember the length
of the Ark is equal to the radius of the
circle this green angle formed here is 1
radian that's the concept of radians
actually there's radius everywhere
around this angle r r and r and that's
probably why they call it
radians if you understood this concept
well then understanding the conversion
between degrees and radians would be a
cakewalk now let's try and see how one
can be written in terms of another we
know the formula for the circumference
of a circle it equals 2 piun R where R
is the radius now observe the figure
really well the length of this red Arc
is R which is the length of the radius
how many such arcs would we need to
cover the entire circumference think
about
it we have the formula in front of us
yes we would need 2 pi of such ARS since
Pi is approximately
3.14 we will have 2 ultied 3.14 which
equals 6.28 ARS we would need 6.28 ARS
of length
R 6.28 ARS sounds weird but let's see
how it's
6.28 we have already drawn one Arc so
let's try drawing more such arcs of the
same length on the
circumference this is the second one
then a third a 4th a fifth and a sixth
and some place left here for 0.28 Ark it
equals 6 arcs plus 28% of one Ark and as
we saw one Arc corresponds to one radian
at the center so how many radians will
one full rotation cover at the center
yes one full rotation equals 2 pi
radians at the center it simply means
that if we rotate one arm completely
then two 2 pi radians will be covered at
the center but wait we also know that
one full rotation equals
360° from these two equations we can say
that 2 pi radians equals
360° now it's very simple to express one
in the form of another if 2 pi radians
equals
360° then one radian equals how many de
1 radian will equal
360° / 2 2 pi we know that 2 * 180 is
360 hence one radian will equal
180° by pi the value of pi is
approximately
3.14 so this approximately equals
57.2
58° well there you go 1 radian equals
57.2 58° there are a few more things we
can deduce from what we just learned
2 pi radians equal
360° this is actually full
rotation this means that when an arm
rotates completely it covers 2 pi
radians if we divide both sides by two
we get Pi radians equal
180° and 180° is half circle or a
straight line the angle subtended by a
semicircular Arc at the center is pi
radians and we can again divide this by
two to get < by 2 radians equal 90°
which is actually a right angle so a
right angle is equivalent to PI by 2
radians let's erase this to understand
the most important thing we should take
away from this video remember 1 radian
is equal to 180° by pi this is
approximately equal to 180° by 3.14
since Pi is approximately
3.14 solving this we get one radian
approximately equal to
57.2
58° 1 radian is just like any other
angle in degree like this this measures
one radian which is
58° if you're still unclear about
radians don't worry about it watch this
video again and I'm sure it will make
more
sense
[Music]